SPEAKER 1: Welcome to this
episode of "Click to Deploy,"
a series where we show you how
easy it is to deploy solutions
from Google Cloud marketplace.
In this episode,
we'll be reviewing
how to set up a Confluent Cloud
cluster via the Google Cloud
marketplace.
Confluent is pioneering a
fundamentally new category
of data infrastructure
focused on data in motion.
Its cloud native offering
is the foundational platform
for data in motion,
which is designed
to be the intelligent
connective tissue
to enable real-time data
from multiple sources,
allowing it to constantly
stream across the organization.
And, in fact, Confluent founders
are the original creators
of Apache Kafka and are helping
organizations set their data
in motion even faster with
their fully managed service
for Apache Kafka.
Now let's explore how to set
up a Confluent Cloud cluster.
Let's start by searching for
Confluent Cloud in the Google
Cloud marketplace.
For this demo, we'll choose
the solution Apache Kafka
on Confluent Cloud.
The landing page will display
information about the solution,
details about
pricing, and support.
The pricing information
displays a high level estimate
of charges.
Pricing for this solution is
based on your subscription
plan.
Let's click the Subscribe
button to launch the solution.
Start first by choosing
a billing account
and agreeing to the
terms below, which
are the terms about
subscription fee billed monthly
and canceling the service.
You'll also notice the
pricing calculator,
which can help you see
estimated costs based
on factors like time frame
and subscription plan.
Once your purchase
has been accepted,
you will see another page,
which requires you to register
with Confluent Cloud.
You'll be able to manage Apache
Kafka on Confluent Cloud.
Make sure to sign in or log in
with your Confluent account.
On Confluent Cloud, we
will set up a cluster.
For the purpose of this demo,
I will create a basic cluster.
Choose a region.
We'll choose US 4, Las Vegas.
Choose an availability.
We'll choose single zone.
Now we'll launch our cluster.
Next, let's test for our
cluster using Confluent CLI
on the Google Cloud shell.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING]
There you have it, Apache
Kafka on Confluent Cloud
with a click of a button.
If you enjoyed this video,
please subscribe and hit
the Like button below.
We encourage you to check
out the GCP Marketplace
and deploy the
solution on your own.
Thanks for watching.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING]